joining us now a man who has spent his
entire nfl career with the pittsburgh
steelers now entering year five
four years ago he was a second round
pick of the
same pittsburgh steelers team mvp in
2018. here he is receiver
juju smith schuster juju welcome back
how are you pal
i'm good man uh thanks for having back
man this is awesome pretty cool
and i got to say thank you in advance to
the folks at sherman for making you
available we'll talk more coming up
about what you have going on with them
but watching the draft this weekend and
seeing the reactions and seeing the
moments and the anticipation of the hope
and everything that goes into it what's
the one thing
that stands out for you the one memory
that you'll never
forget from your draft experience
i got a phone call and it was uh it was
my postmates from mcdonald's it was
outside
it wasn't it wasn't a team and i got so
hyped because
you know on that on that day you tell
your friends you tell your family hey
don't mess with me on this day like you
know between this time and this time
like
i'm expecting phone calls from a you
know a team for a head coach you know
owners and
i was so nervous i was so hungry i was
like man before i go to life
i'm gonna have like one of my favorite
meals to mcdonald's so order mcdonald's
i get a phone call i'm thinking like you
know
it's a it's a coach and
i'm looking at the area code i'm not
familiar with it it's it's
we're in laguna beach or newport beach
and it's a number i'm not familiar with
and i answer it's like hey
who's outside you want to bring this up
i'm just like hello coach oh
my gosh and that's probably that's
probably the most funniest
memories on my job day i can remember
that's amazing you were drafted by
mcdonald's
unfortunately for the the steelers you
didn't you didn't sign the contract
the uh the draft now that your four
years removed from it
established how much attention do you
pay to it especially as it relates to
the guys that your team
is adding through the process i mean
it's it's it's a big thing you know
um you know honestly you know at my age
20 you know yeah guys 20 20 21 22 23 24
guys you know
you know who are all being dropped and
it's like to see you know what
our team is going to have as weapons
next year and you know as you see
our first two rounds were you know two
officer players which is rare because
the sellers
you know they dropped deeps to players
in the first round
they've done at the past like eight to
ten years so to see them drop
a tight end to see them drive a running
back you know it shows that
you know they're bringing weapons for
for big ben a hat you know so
i'm super excited uh to see you know
obviously what we got going on and just
go out there and dominate i mean you
were there to experience it the entire
season looking back on it now what was
missing
from the running game was it blocking
was it commitment to the run was it
the tailbacks necessary obviously the
steelers think that they get a guy like
nanjay harris it's going to make a
difference but what did you
perceive in the running game last year
that kept it from being what it needed
to be
i think i think we just have to you know
stay true to our run game and you know
and mix it up
um i think a lot of the times you know
we we sometimes
you know we love to throw the ball and
you know i don't mind it you know
we throw and we catch and we run it but
at the same time you know we have to go
in there we have to blog as receivers we
have the buckets tied in and
um it's going to be a very interesting
year to see how our run game
plays out you know not having marquis
fantasy as our center as a captain
uh we'll be tough not having al on the
outside
uh you know i think our only that guy
would be dave castro
um you know you have you know zach
banner chooks
but you know nigey harris is a huge
commitment you know for our offense you
know now
you know james connor is not with us
anymore and i'm just very curious to see
how that happens to plan out but you
know
more heavy on the run game and you know
moving players around
you got a an extended look at what the
business of football is like and
unfortunately it was in a year with a
reduced salary cap free agency was
different than it's ever been
from your perspective what was that
you know big picture experience like for
you to enter free agency in a year where
things were so crazy
oh man i'll probably say it i think free
agency
was probably you know more nerve
wrecking and racking in than than uh
draft day
knowing that i'm able to pick a team
where i can go the teams i offer but
then again like not knowing what will
happen
because of the salary was so low and
everything this year did not
you know play out to how i wanted to be
you know when i looked about like
back five four years and it's a lot
different you know so
it's it's betting on myself going with
the team i've been with you know before
and going out and you know trying to get
paid again
there was a poll question on social
media regarding your future before free
agency began and the options were
as to the question of whether you will
stay in pittsburgh i hope so and that's
a negative and you actually voted
that's a negative most people thought
you weren't going to be back with the
steelers apparently including you what
made you think you weren't going to be a
steeler again
um just just with everything that you
know was it going on
you know you know obviously just leading
up to it you know saying that you know i
will
i will become a free agency before
anybody knew so i just knew that on my
own and i was just like
you know hey obviously it's business you
know they can't afford me
uh at the moment but then again like if
you look at the the cap salary it was
very very low this year
so um
it just came down to like last minute
you know it really came down to a while
between picking between pittsburgh
chiefs and baltimore on where i wanted
to go where i fit best you know for when
you do
how far into the process because it took
a week or so
when during that that
period of time did the door open
to stay in pittsburgh when it seemed
like it had been closed
yeah i would say i would say that when i
hit free agency
they wanted to see where i ended up at
just wanted to see where the market was
at
um and it just goes off very slow you
know
receivers were kind we were taking off
you know slow slowly like day two day
three day four
and i was on a back end you know on day
four day five you know waiting to see
um you know other teams to the offer was
you know
ten 9 mil with incentives and you know
pittsburgh was offering
uh eight mil and i was just like well
honestly like if it came down to this
um going going back to know where i
you know i know my quarterback i know my
receiver coach i know my offense i have
the relationship
they know me they know my body and just
betting on myself is
you know something that i've looked at
you know and i don't regret it at all
and is the plan let's give it a year
let's see what happens and then next
year
maybe things will be back to normal the
market will be back to normal
and the offers will be quicker they'll
be more reflective of my skills and we
just see what happens then
yeah man to see you see what happened i
mean if it's all wielding plays out you
know i would love to be a student for
the next four years
um that'll be a total of nine years you
know playing for them
and um just throw this cap will be a lot
higher
i think they're top five next year so
we'll see how that goes
speaking of nine i saw on your twitter
that you're at least pondering
the possibility of dropping the one and
going with number nine
uh is that something you're seriously
considering and have they told you how
much
you would have to pay for all the unsold
19 smith shuster jerseys
that's the thing though i think um the
biggest thing
is that i'm marketable 19 so well but
then again like
all you need is a black sharpie to just
go
i mean how hard is that i think a
sharpie costs like two three dollars you
know
what are you doing the road jersey
though
wide out black sharpie are gonna work on
the road jersey a wide out
white out white paint there you go white
paint
so that's so we're sticking with 19
that's what you're saying i'm sticking
with 19 but
if it comes down to i mean chris boswell
has nine
uh he he will for him for me for him to
give out the
return for him to give out he's he's
probably asking for a check
so i doubt it i saw a lot of players
i saw you said somewhere after you
signed the the
ranking was actually steelers then
chiefs then ravens at the chiefs for the
second choice
how how close did you come to being a
member of the chiefs
very close man um you know i got
andy reid sending me uh
trophies of the lombardi trophy and and
and
um talking to the coaches and ever it's
you know
when you have an opportunity to play on
an organization like that you know who
you know they win they they they put
numbers up they perform
uh it was it was very close you know but
i think
i think more of uh more story was
um i just feel more comfortable you know
just being home that i already
know like where i'm at you know
everything's already there
um knowing that i can play one more year
at ben and everything he's done for me
uh you know means a lot and the loyalty
is there too
do you think it is just one more year
for ben before he retires i don't know
we'll see man um
i feel like a lot of guys think you know
hey you got one more year one more year
one more year
and one more year turn into two three
years and you know lay down the road
and if you win if he if i if he stays
hopefully i stay but you just never know
hey tell us what you have going on with
sharmin
yeah so partner with charmin uh
basically you know
meetings like this or interviews all day
you know constantly in meetings day in
day out
charming has created this thing called
brb bot
which basically you can activate the bot
while you go use the bathroom
you can without being disrespectful or
rude at
all which is amazing and having a
obviously your time alone and you know
gain away for an amount of time and
it's really cool man uh you know just
messing around with it myself and
me being asked questions day in day out
and repeat
repetitively i think it works out
perfect and
it's a great way it's a great way for
the digital world you know with
everything else happening like zoom
calls and meetings and all that so
it's really a great great uh tool for us
in the future
so it's actually something you could use
during a call like this while you go
take care of business
yes prefer to be honest preferably more
of a
of a meeting call but more people want
to
the one-on-one is different because
there's a lot of there's a lot of going
back and forth
on speaking but if you were to set it as
you know you said it as personal
you could set it as business and more so
you want to use it
in a group setting home hey before i let
you run
i would be remiss to not ask you about
the comment that you made before the
playoff game against the cleveland
browns when you said the browns is the
browns and
how much do you think honestly
that motivated them in that game
probably a lot honestly i'm not gonna
lie to you
it got to the point where you know the
cleveland browns you know had a
billboard up
in cleveland that's saying browns is the
browns you know i i think
by me saying that you know it says that
you know a lot of people care about what
i say and my voice and my opinion
um at the end of the day you know i said
what i said i don't say anything back
you know they did come out there they
did whip our ass
and i'm not and that's completely um
no that it is what it is you know we
lost that game you know and
we lost early in that game within the
first you know five ten minutes but we
still fought and i'll tell you one thing
about our team we still fought to the
end
and you know like i said it wasn't good
enough but um
i just know that our afc north is
probably the
hardest the hardest hardest division
right now to win and
guys like joe barrel lamar jackson baker
mayfield
and ben and and i think every team is
going to getting to the point where like
man they're really good so um
it is what it is was that an eye opening
for you though i mean
do you and maybe we all need to go
through that
part of our journey where we realize
holy crap
somebody's actually listening to me
reacting to me
i need to factor that in when i say
things in the future
yeah i mean uh i mean obviously i know
what i'm saying and i don't
you know everything i said i don't
regret you know usually i
when i when i speak out a term you know
it's you know i speak
you know as what i say so for the most
part
i think anything i do on social media is
a very you know people are
willing to catch it you know but the
response for example me doing
quarterback overt
i get hit you know the ball is done to
me uh and i get hit i get blown up
you know people turn out into like the
biggest news you know it's good media
you know it like i said it is what it is
i i
gotta take it as i said it you know um
but there's no regret there's no regret
at all you know you live you learn and
you know speaking into the future you
got to respect teams got to respect the
team's loyal got to respect the teams
that i'm playing against and
like i said our division is really hard
this year and i'll be surprised to see
that we will have some great games
hey last one real quick there's been a
lot of talk about players showing up not
showing up for the workouts at the team
facility where do you stand on that how
much if any are you going to be there
for the voluntary off season
uh for the most part i'll be there um
you know right now everything's just
virtual
and uh zoom and stuff like that so yeah
all right hey jay
uh juju we appreciate some of your time
we say uh to you all the best
congratulations on your success
and uh safe travels enjoy the rest of
the off season we hope to talk to you
again soon
thank you i appreciate it hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports